you can have fun me I know I cut up yeah
I'm really excited this game seems
really cool actually
this game is hard really have you ever
played Mobile's before yeah no good
there's okay well then you should be
fine
all right I'm just gonna go for the
classic yeah the one with boobs
um Katherine yes this okay you guys know
what I pick now damn it this is
literally my first real game so and ha
you can't hold it against me from back
yeah kissing kiss Sam look at it I feel
like I shouldn't say what I'm doing cuz
I know you guys are listening no okay
I'm gonna try my bubble thing cause I
don't know where this okay I'm a bubble
now got my first kill
oh my god I'm the best player ever okay
me and why they're kicking ass already
yep oh [ __ ] it came from the forest ha
ha ha no one warned me about the fourth
Hey I know dogs
oh yeah oh nice
oh yeah yeah that's just cuz uh
someone's gonna pop out of the forest so
no one's no one's gonna pop out of my
forest no man I'm tapping so much Jesus
Christ I like to tapping it's addicting
okay no don't
how dare you how dare you what'd you get
Oh exciting you know you know what's
weird get up get up you're going down
that way
ah I'm so sorry
ready [ __ ] no no you didn't sheesh no
you did not kill me
goddamnit okay alright fine you know
what you got lucky it's okay I'm legit
pissed now
oh I can't do much I this tickle me
everyone is aiming for pute yeah it's
okay I got bubbles that's where you're
supposed to do anyway
oh my god oh my god what is that you
want to [ __ ] is that
Roxanne Joe come for you never worry
everybody is purified oh no what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you
no stop
Sami help me Sammis he's looking at me
[ __ ] it's a me do it
[ __ ] you guys are you standing around
what are you doing Sammy what are you
doing Sammy nice is much what the hell
come on
hahaha what yes
um um they know it's calling you
no no cheesecake no oh my god I don't
think that was bad for my first game but
yeah no we got destroyed
autocorrect it up yeah you were pretty
good
haha it's pretty much well does it have
fun right me ringing wait have fun we're
not here to have fun
who said how dare you expect too much
from us don't expect anything from me
then well okay we need we need like a
speech so our morale is good go ahead
and fight hard and believe in yourself
because no one else actually you know
what I'm aro very motivated now thank
you very much and you have my life for
you now huh
you should risky I'll take a bullet for
you now let's feed your so good
no oh my god this guy does so much
damage I know
well my beginning game isn't very strong
I just died well you did it but you know
later my game gets real strong and watch
out alright alright I hear much
everything ah ah run run for your life
the [ __ ] was that are you guys holding
the iPad it gets so heavy it's like
exercise while playing games they're
actually starting to make them heavier
just so people you guys power need help
I'm coming I'm coming
it's too late okay I got a stun going oh
you did Brep ah no what
where did he come from we'll sing songs
about your heroism sing it now Oh cutie
pie oh my god hey okay I'm done I can't
can't do it the ghost appears his prowl
don't worry about it Oh what the junk
ethnic very not good
oh [ __ ] was that yeah I lied I can't do
anything I'm sorry it's okay
don't worry about it no enemies getting
ridiculous get to know don't you
run away okay I think we should just
have the Tea Party that I was talking
about oil I'm all for it hey you can't
believe it
no I'm stop it somehow yeah go in there
you did it
you some lemon you can do it on our
pyramid thing we really needed that
all right good game guys good well I did
waver thought look okay anyone who's on
my team will lose as is how it is no way
I wouldn't blame yourself
jet packs welcome hello that's the right
excitement Felix
one question go ahead I had to ask on
someone very precious oh he was asking
what kind of color socks are you wearing
right now dude I am wearing no socks
oh no socks I'm a knock no sock kind of
guy what can I say good surprise ha ha
ha
I had rumors about you losing some games
pew Shh know who said that but the good
thing though Oh Danny - I'm back - fixed
up ok I hope you do as well which one
should I pick he's good talk on he's a
nice talk is really funny man yeah
you can hide he looks cool all right
tacit is fun okay everyone calm down I'm
a fox I'm happy all right what items
should I get the recommend I am some
good eyes good ones bigger ones got it
thank you so much man the jungle life
this is the best life I ever had you're
my jungle brother yes you're my jungle
another market whatever way take it take
it take ha ha ha ah yes thank you
confidence just went straight up buddy
so why are we here oh yeah this is a
shop this don't laugh that's where you
buy things
yeah fold in one blog come on heads and
the best play in the world
I did a flip and then he died and it was
awesome Oh God jet packs
you're insane what are you doing you
want this manly boom just meant like
yeah how is that manly back up back up
back up I go whoo well I hope it was
worth it good job back see brother look
like great
well I guess another round I lose huh
that's fine yeah it's okay nah hey guys
Catherine can fine-tune PLP by Hilde IOT
I only [ __ ] [ __ ] what the [ __ ] was
that well then we're all dead
together okay cool
great oh my god now a mighty miner going
down yeah
I'm just chilling guys don't worry about
it hey how's it going everyone cool
that's great are you doing cook save me
hey I'm a box I'm a box I'm a box okay
guys I want to apologize for all the
sins I had committed these last hour
okay we should probably get the [ __ ] out
of here why you hit me what the [ __ ] I'm
a box I'm a box Brett can't see me okay
oh [ __ ]
appropriate reaction for grandma calling
oh my god grandma's calling me guys no
no goo goo goo goo goo oh I'm a box I'm
a box
stupid mice [ __ ] second time oh no it's
over
yeah ain't over till it's over don't hit
me what what's happening in the base
wait wait what did you guys vote to
forfeit no so good no we would never do
that so so we were so good that we won
because we were good
oh my God thank you so much